You're here Agent Coulson of shield you've come to save us. Yeah, just to clarify. Where is here who is us and from what?
Have you ever flown a spaceship? You know the answer to that question
What do they want from us? All they ever want.
Submission
We need to split up. Oh hell no. Haven't you ever seen an alien movie? We'll cover the most ground.
Thats exactly what they say before they get picked off one by one, and you know who the first one will be.
Marvel's agents of shield returns on a new night Friday starting December 1st
On ABC hey everybody new agents of shield, let's break it down
So if you didn't know they're in outer space now, they're doing a lot of Captain Marvel infinity war adjacent stuff
So I'll explain sort of the kree-skrull war
What's going on with the villains of the series in sort of adjacent to that what might be happening with the?
Inhumans characters now that they've wrapped up their run because I don't think that that's going to get a season two so if you're finding
Me for the first time be sure to subscribe to get everything
They'll be giveaway stuff at the end of the video too because we saw up a whole bunch of movie stuff going on
But the big thing first if you haven't watched agents of shield in a while Coulson got mysteriously
Abducted along with the other people at the end of last season they seemed humanoid
But he just woke up on this spaceship in this shot here staring at this asteroid belt like what the hell is going on
So right away the immediate theory was is that we were doing agents of sword?
Which is just the space-based version of shield?
And it was a way to switch things up before infinity war and do more cosmic things so they did a New York Comic
Con panel where they answered some specific questions they did say they are not doing agents of sword we know whatever this
Organization is going to be called. It's not sword
They're gonna be a slightly different group, but the antagonist of the trailer is one the alien looking monster
Which might be some sort of Kree hybrid or it could be one of the brood along with normal Kree soldiers
So if you haven't watched shield in a couple seasons refresher
That's how they explain Coulson coming back from the dead after he was killed during the Avengers movie Nick Fury
Experimented on Kree soldiers to take their blood and turn it into a measure of last resort for dead Avengers
So if somebody like Thor or Captain America were to die they needed anime
solution to bring them back to the battlefield so that they could win the day so the magic potion they
Created was what was used to bring Coulson back to life, but it was this crazy traumatic experience
So that was their sort of crossover with the Kree guardians of the galaxy stuff because guardians of the galaxy was the real
introduction to the Kree
But now the thing that agents of shield is doing because we're getting ready for infinity war is is pushing into kree-skrull war
Which is Captain Marvel territory? I'll talk about Captain Marvel stuff in a minute, too
Because that's more shield Nick Fury crossover which is also more Coulson crossover, but that's set back during the 90s
So it's a little bit different in present day were ramping up for Thanos to start collecting the infinity gems
So space is turning into this very divided
Territory where you have people that support Thanos and people that are trying to avoid him
So it just allows them to do
Infinity war stuff without having to worry about direct crossover because most of the infinity war stuff is going to be happening on planet earth
Then they move into outer space and you'll pricey more that during Avengers 4
So the extra characters that they've added this star-lord looking character here might wind up being
Jacked flag who was a member of the guardians of the galaxy for a little while in the comics?
He's sort of your Han Solo roguish character sort of like the stand-in for star-lord, maybe they'll tease some chemistry with Daisy's character
She's like you know the young ingenue on the show so typically when you bring in a young male character
That looks kind of like han Solo you have to assume that that's who they're intending her to have chemistry with
The actor's name is jeff ward. He just teased that he's a magnetic soft-spoken
charismatic guy
Which reads a lot like star-lord who he himself like in the guardians of the galaxy movies is based a lot on the Han Solo
Character just very roguish charismatic guy in outer space who's you know relatively redeemable, but does a lot of bad things?
But the thing with Captain Marvel obviously, I don't think that brie Larson is going to be anywhere near this TV
Show you just have to remember the Captain Marvel is largely based in and around the kree-skrull war
During the 90s and that sort of like the Hundred Years War it just goes on and on and on
So that part of space is sort of in perpetual conflict, so that's really where you get into the stuff
They're teasing in this trailer
Just like this ongoing war
The Ghost Rider was talking about last season so again catch up if you didn't watch the end of last season
Ghost Rider came back at the end in tol Coulson that he'd been on other
Planets fighting in this crazy space war now
They've revealed one of the big sides of that through the Kree so obviously the scrolls are always the other side of that
So I'm really happy that shield is able to do stuff like that
It'll be interesting to see how they tackle all that lore and how they weave in Captain Marvel infinity war Easter eggs
So if you've been watching my infinity war videos since comic-con they basically made this huge announcement that Captain Marvel kree-skrull war
said in the 90s
Between the infinity war movies because one it opens up a whole new group of characters
We've never done the scrolls in the Marvel Universe neither this big new antagonistic group, but it also explains
Why Captain Marvel wasn't around for the events of the first Avengers movie? Why she wasn't around during phase one and phase two?
Because she was still in outer space
policing this Kree Scroll war in a different part of the galaxy
So just don't be surprised if when we get to the Captain Marvel movie you see a lot of
similarities to the stuff fate teased with this agents of shield
Story in the cool thing about the Captain Marvel movie
Is that because Nick Fury is going to be in the 90s and have both of his eyes?
He's probably going to lose one of those eyes during the kree-skrull war
We might also get some more Coulson at the beginning of that movie, too
I'm
Assuming if they do go into deep space during that movie then Coulson will only be featured on
Planet earth at the beginning of the movie and like brief scenes like oh my god Coulson's back, but it's in the 90s
So he hasn't gone through all the events of the Avengers yet, so that's why he's still alive
But for everybody that wants to see Coulson in the movies again that is the place to do it
The whole thing about shield this season is that it's taking the time slot that Inhumans had so originally they were gonna premiere it in
January next year
But I think because Inhumans just performed so poorly
They wanted to speed things up ABC's like please don't bail on our network. So they moved the premiere up to December
There are 22 episodes
I don't know if there's gonna be a break at the end of the year because
Originally when they were gonna premiere in January it was going to be an unbroken run
It was going to be 22 weeks with no break, so I don't know how many episodes
They're gonna air before the end of this year before they go on break and come back in January
Maybe like a one or two week break
We'll find out
but because I don't think that the
Inhumans show is gonna get a season 2 they can bring any of those characters that they want onto agents of shield in the later
Episodes now they probably already shot like the first half of the season, but there's 22 episodes
So you still have all that story in the back half to work them in if you want and for those of you asking about
Ghost Rider yes, I definitely think that he'll come back, but because of the new Disney streaming service
I know everybody's been asking for a Ghost Rider
Netflix show if they wind up doing a Ghost Rider show it will go on that Disney streaming service, and that's not gonna drop till
2019 so I think we'll find out more about what's happening with the Ghost Rider character in the Marvel Universe
Later next year like they'll say okay
We're planning on making a Ghost Rider TV show or they'll say no we're just gonna have him come back to agents of shield every
Season, so just let me know in the comments
What do you guys think about all this then doing agents of shield in space pushing into Captain Marvel guardians of the galaxy?
Infinity war territory. It should be a lot of fun this also explains. Why they're not around for a lot of the movie stuff
They're like why you know why isn't shield helping out with what was happening during spider-man homecoming now
They can say it's because we were captured and taken into space and drummed into this Kree scroll war
But what'll happen is I have new Thor Ragnarok to post this weekend
I'll do a video for all the deleted scenes
There was a whole bunch of Odin that they cut out of the movie, so that'll post on Sunday
I have a new flash prophecy video to post next that'll be later tonight and then obviously next week
We have all the Punisher injustice league stuff dropping, so it's a really good time for comic book people
But I'm still giving away IMAX gift certificates all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
Or leave a comment on this video. I'll announce the winner when I post that Thor deleted scenes video tomorrow
You can click here from my non-spoilery Justice League reaction, and you can click here for my new Punisher trailer
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight